I would argue that the first two answers are the ones that are more accurate.
Picture of faces certainly do have many pixels.
A one megapixel camera will have a million input features if
you're using it in the raw input space.
So this is really prime to get some reduction somehow.
because a million features would be really difficult for, say, an SVM to handle.
The second thing that's true is that there are some underlying patterns in
faces that is really well suited for PCA.
So since we think that there are just a few underlying latent variables, so
in the example of a one megapixel image,
I wouldn't say that there's a million points of difference between two faces.
That there will just be a few general points of difference and
that maybe PCA can, can tease those out and use them to their maximum ability.
And the third thing that I wouldn't say is true is that facial recognition is
simple using machine learning.
For example, a decision tree will have a lot of difficulty trying to do
facial recognition.
As we'll see in the following code example using PCA and, say,
an SVM together, you can get a lot of power.
But in general, even though it's something that humans do quite easily.
We have brains that are particularly well optimized for recognizing each other.
It's an evolutionary advantage.
And computers a priori don't necessarily have that ability.
So doing facial recognition with machine learning,
while it's a well understood problem at this point, is something that is
maybe a little bit trickier than you would naively first guess.